es ist ein sehr seltsames relikt aus dem
weltall was jetzt für aufsehen sorgt
flensburg der elster mit den wir kennen
der wasser enthält und den hat der mann
im herbst 2009 10 beim rasenmähen in
seinem flensburger garten gefunden das
sensationelle dieser methode ist jetzt
mit an der lösung eines der größten
rätsel der astronomie beteiligt wie kam
das wasser auf die erde klicks und
future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst hab' sich wie kommen die
größten rätsel der wissenschaft werden
in den meisten fällen nicht dadurch
gelöst dass einfach so etwas vom himmel
fällt in diesem wirklich spektakulären
fall aber ist das anders die rede ist
von einem metroid der planeten
forschende weltweit in aufregung
versetzt sein name flensburg benannt
nach seinem fundort in norddeutschland
bereits im herbst 2009 10 kam es zu
diesem sensationellen methoden von der
tatsächlich jetzt weil der aufklärung
eines der größten ungelösten rätsel der
astronomie hilft woher kommt das wasser
auf der erde aber von vorne
es geschah im september des vergangenen
jahres 2009 10 am himmel über
norddeutschland war ein feuerwerk zu
sehen der von einem lauten knall
begleitet wurde und die menschen in der
region in aufregung versetzt ein
mitglied der in die erdatmosphäre
eingetreten war und dort zum teil
verglühte aber nur zum teil direkt am
darauf folgenden tag dann wurde der
mysteriöse kleine und dunkle steinen auf
gestellen in einem garten in flensburg
war der 24 einhalb gramm leichte krise
gelandet und war den besitzer des
gartens der eigentlich nur rasen mähen
wollte glücklicherweise aufgefallen
wenig später stand bereits fest dass es
sich tatsächlich um ein überrest vom
ereignis des vortages handeln muss
fachleute weltweit interessierten sich
für den meteoriten rest rendsburg und
die analysen bestätigten in kürzester
zeit dass es sich um einen wirklich
spektakulären fund handelt markus pabst
vom institut für planetologie der
universität münster hatten genauer unter
die lupe genommen und erstaunliches
festgestellt mit diesen methoden ist
etwas geschehen was an unsere
wasserkocher erinnert und wie man das
altwasser wasser kind dann bildet sich
auch nachlässt
und ja im prinzip nichts anderes als
kreis in carbonat und von denen haben
wir da sehr viele drin
und während der untersuchung hat sich
auch gezeigt dass die karbonate in
flensburg die theorie dann halten sind
das dass die bisher am ältesten
datierten carbonari sind die existieren
das heißt sie haben sich ja es sind die
ältesten klasse die wir bis jetzt aus
dem sonnensystem kennen wie aus
wässrigen lösungen entstanden sind es
ist damit der älteste nachweis von
wasser aus unserem sonnensystem der auf
der erde existiert in zahlreichen
medienberichten ist von einem zitat
bedeutendsten wissenschaftlichen kunden
deutschlands die rede
mittlerweile wurde der meteorit wirklich
auf herz und nieren geprüft daran waren
zahlreiche internationale
forschungsinstitute beteiligt die den
kleinen stein mit einem durchmesser von
drei etwa 300 cm
sowohl chemisch als auch mineralogische
ganz genau unter die lupe nahmen die
analysen zeigen dass dieser meteorit und
wirklich extrem selten und somit ganz
besonders spannend für die wissenschaft
ist denn verglichen werden kann er nur
mit einer bislang sehr selten gefallenen
gruppe an meteoriten in der fachsprache
ist von den so genannten kollegen
konnten die rede
untersuchungen mit
rasterelektronenmikroskop legen nahe
dass flensburg mineralien enthält die
sich in der frühphase des sonnensystems
gebildet haben müssen und zwar unter
beteiligung von wasser flensburg weiß
vor allem karbonate und schichtdicke
karte auf und genau das macht ihn für
forschende wie beispielsweise den
münsteraner planetenforscher markus
barth 6 so spannend es ist ja nicht nur
das facebook der da jetzt regelmäßig mal
neu ist oder auch nicht und auch noch
unbekannt war
es gibt ja immer mal wieder solche fälle
oder funde oder neue meteoriten gefunden
werden die in keiner bisher bekannten
klassifikation passen und das spricht
natürlich dafür dass da wirklich eine
sehr große variabilität erste und
wahrscheinlich auch immer noch herrscht
die wir nicht kennen die aber durchaus
sehr eine lösung bringen könnte dazu um
zu erklären wie wasser auf der erde ja
wie das auf die erde gekommen ist und ob
es vielleicht sogar schon vorher war
damit ist flensburg ein weiterer sehr
wichtiger puzzlestein denn dieser
meteoriten von kann und wo mehr über die
ursprünge unseres planeten berichten und
damit sprit
der eine der größten fragen der
wissenschaft an woher stammt das wasser
auf der erde fest steht ja die erde ist
ein wasser planet und rund drei viertel
der erdoberfläche ist von ozean bedeckt
außerdem gilt wasser als ursprung allen
lebens auf der erde
doch noch immer nicht ist ein gültig
geklärt woher das ganze wasser stammt
ein rätsel das gleichzeitig auch den
ursprung allen lebens und somit auf
unserer existenz beinhaltet im großen
und ganzen gibt es zwei lager in der
wissenschafts community einige
forschende vertreten die these dass die
erde seit ihrer entstehung wasser
enthält und das wasser in unseren
ozeanen und flüssen aus dem inneren des
planeten stammt demnach soll das wasser
schon von beginn an in dem material
enthalten gewesen seien aus dem die erde
vor langer zeit einmal zusammenklappte
das wasser sei zunächst im gestein
eingeschlossen und seien dann als gas
aus dem magma ausgeströmt und flüssig
geworden doch die folgenden überlegungen
stellen diese hypothese in frage liegt
unser ehrt planet für diese annahme
nicht viel zu nahe an der sonne würde
die hitze der sonne
die entstehung solcher gigantischer
wassermassen auf der erde überhaupt
zulassen
gegen diese hypothese spricht auch die
annahme dass sich die erde in ihrer
frühzeit vermutlich in einer wasser
freien region des sonnensystems nämlich
im inneren der mars umlaufbahn gefunden
hat die wohl weitaus akzeptierte theorie
geht davon aus dass wurde asteroiden und
kometen das irdische wasser mitbrachten
als sie auf die junge erde einschlagen
hinweise darauf liefert die sogenannten
chemischen signaturen die des ozean
wassers und des wassers aus asteroiden
die sind sich nämlich sehr ähnlich waren
es möglicherweise sogar asteroiden oder
kometen aus den äußeren bereichen des
sonnensystems die bei einem aufprall auf
die erde das wasser geliefert haben
sowohl kosten als auch meteoriten
bestehen zu einem großen anteil aus
wasser so dass tatsächlich keine krassen
einsteige von nötigen gewesen werden um
die mengen an wasser die sich auf
unserem planeten befindet
bereitzustellen
doch bezüglich dieser theorie gibt es
einige ungeklärte fragen und
ungereimtheiten beispielsweise die
gigantischen wasserreservoire im tiefen
inneren der erde das gestein dort
speichert nämlich mindestens doppelt so
viel wasser wie in allen weltmeeren
enthalten ist und seine signatur gleicht
dem wasser der asteroiden eben nicht
wirklich konkret geht es um den gehalt
von deuterium dieser ist im wasser des
tiefen erdmantels deutlich niedriger als
beim asteroiden
ähnlich bei den wasserreichen kometen
die ebenso nicht wirklich in dieses bild
passen
durch die raumsonde rosetta nämlich
konnte man herausfinden dass die
isotopen signatur des kometen wasser es
eben nicht mit der signatur der
irdischen ozeane übereinstimmt heißt
also eine umfassende erklärung dafür was
damals auf der jungen erde geschafft
kann diese theorie nicht liefern und zu
tüfteln forschungsteams weltweit ohne
unterlass über die eine so spannende
frage wie genau kam das wasser auf die
erde der planetenforscher marcus patrick
aus münster jedenfalls beschreibt den
flensburg methoden als einzigartig
seiner meinung nach spricht eher dafür
dass bereits als sehr junger
sonnensystem flüssiges wasser enthalten
haben muss und zwar in größerer menge
markus platzeck ist sich deshalb sicher
das ist zeigt es deutlich mehr
variabilität im system vorhanden war
und das ist sehr wahrscheinlich ist dass
ein teil des wassers wie groß der teil
weiß ich wie groß dieser teil war weiß
ich nicht kann ich nicht beantworten
aber dass auf jeden fall einen teil
durch den eintrag von meteoriten oder
wünsche oder auch kometen auf die erde
gekommen ist doch flensburg könnte uns
nicht nur bei dem rätsel um die wasser
frage weiterhelfen er liefert zudem auch
vergleichsmaterial für andere
möglicherweise wasserhaltiges zu ihnen
und manche davon könnten der erde und
dem leben auf ihr gefährlich werden so
zum beispiel der us open der sich etwa
alle sechs jahre der erde nähert manchen
berechnung zufolge besteht die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass da zwischen den
jahren 2000 175 und 2199 mit der erde
kollidiert die nasa raumsonde rosetta ex
hatte pendelt an besuch abgestattet und
dabei eine super spannende entdeckung
gemacht die rede ist von felsen auf
seiner oberfläche die adern enthalten
absorptions beobachtung im infraroten
spektralbereich offenbaren dass diese
teilweise mehr als einen meter langen
adern mit karbonat gefüllten für die
fachwelt ist klar dass solche struktur
nicht auf wenn du selbst gebildet worden
seien besonderen von seinem vorgänger
körper stammen müssen beispielsweise
wenn flüssigkeit durch risse im hass so
fließt und sich so carbon mineralien
ablagern in den köpfen der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
also ein wirklich spannendes szenario
möglicherweise hat auf dem etwa 100 km
großen ursprungs körper von benny ein
offener wasserkreislauf wechsel
hier könnte wasser aus seinem inneren
nach außen gedrückt worden sein und zwar
aufgrund des druckausgleich dann wurde
das wasser dieser hypothese zur folge in
den interplanetaren raum abgegeben klar
ist jedenfalls dass die mineralogische
beschaffenheit von benny sehr an
kohlenstoffhaltige konkreten erinnert
auch diese beobachtung stützen die idee
dass ein großteil des wassers auf der
erde durch einschläge von körpern
herrührt die asten wie beendet
es bleibt also spannend und hier geht es
weiter mit einem video was der youtube
algorithmus genau für dich ausgesucht
hat also drauf klicken und natürlich
klicks zum science in future abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran